TODD KERPELMAN: Hello,
game developers.
And welcome back to another
exciting episode of "Game On."
I am your host, Todd Kerpelman,
on the Play Games
Developer Relations Team.
And we're going to jump right
into this week's episode.
So you know how last week we had
two presentations, and we
didn't really have any
news and updates?
Well, this time around, we're
doing the reverse.
We don't have any presentations,
but it's all
news and updates.
It's our exciting News
and Updates episode.
And let's just get
right to it.
So first, we're going to start
by talking about Game Services
statistics.
We just started introducing some
basic game services stats
into the Google Play
Developer Console.
You can see an example here.
We're looking at a couple
of sample games
that we have available.
On this front page here, you can
see the number of people
who have signed into your game
using Play Games Services.
Don't get confused by the
column header players.
That's a little misleading.
This isn't people who are
playing your game, but players
who have signed into Game
Services with your game.
The actual number of people
playing your game is probably
going to be larger than this.
Also, if you go into your
Achievements screen within
Game Services, you
will now see a
Percentage Complete stat.
These are the number of players
who have signed in who
have earned this achievement.
So this is a really good way to
look and see if there are
any achievements that are
too difficult to get.
So we're looking at Bruno's
sample game here-- "Firewall
Defense." And you can see that
there are a number of
achievements where the percent
complete is basically zero.
And so he's probably made those
achievements too hard.
This is a common trap for
all you game developers.
You play your game
for weeks on end.
You understand how it works
inside and out.
And achievements that seem
really easy for you to get are
very difficult for your
average player.
So this is a good way to go back
and just kind of sanity
check your assumptions and see
if those achievements really
are as easy or as difficult
as you thought they were.
In addition, you will now be
able to see the number of
unique players who have
submitted a score to each of
your leader boards.
And this is useful if, say,
you have different leader
boards for different levels.
You suddenly have an idea of how
many people have completed
each one of your different
levels, because obviously, you
can see the number of
score completions
for each one of those.
So I know that by themselves,
these stats are interesting,
but they might be data that
you already have if you're
using any kind of third-party
analytics tool already.
But I think maybe the
interesting point here is that
we have all the plumbing now
attached so that we can get
data from the Play Games
Services down to the developer
console and up to you,
the game developer.
So what we have here is
a pretty nice start.
And more importantly, we have
a nice foundation for us to
start showing you a lot more
interesting statistics
regarding Game Services.
So now that we've got all of
the plumbing hooked up and
we've got a few basic things in
there, expect to see some
more stats from us
in the future.
So I don't know.
I think this is kind of cool.
Hopefully you do too.
In addition, we've just launched
Game Insights on the
developer console.
We call it Game Insights because
"Mistakes That You're
Making" sounds kind
of negative.
But that's kind of
what these are.
These are our way of alerting
you to errors in your game
that you might not notice as a
developer, one of the most
important being that your game
has exceeded the rate limit.
For some reason, you're calling
achievements.increment
too often, or there's some bug
in your program that's calling
some method on a loop that
it shouldn't be.
In the past, these were very
hard for you to detect, right?
You have to kind of look for
status codes being returned
from your client and maybe log
those somewhere or something.
If this is happening
in the wild.
It's very hard for you as
a developer to know
what's going on.
So now, if we notice that your
app is getting throttled, we
immediately give you an alert
in the developer console.
So look for those.
In addition, you
can look for--
I think probably our most
common error that we see
happening with game developers
is that you've published an
update your game, but you forgot
to hit Publish in the
Game Services section.
What that means is that you've
got games out there that are
trying to, for instance,
complete an achievement or
submit scores to a leader board,
and your Game Services
are not published.
And the system says, oh wait,
I don't want to make these
available yet, and it
rejects those calls.
What I think is actually
particularly tricky about this
particular error is that Game
Services will allow calls from
anybody who is on the tester
list, which probably includes
you, the game developer.
So you might have people saying,
hey, I can't earn this
achievement.
What's wrong?
And you try it out, and you
say, it looks fine to me.
That's because you're
on the tester list.
You're able to submit or
complete achievements to
non-published achievements in
leaderboards, and normal
players cannot.
And so, this error does happen
a lot, and a lot of
developers miss this.
And so now, we service this as
well on the developer console,
if this happens to you.
And there's a third error.
A little less common, but there
are times when your game
tries to unlock an achievement
or submit a score to a
leaderboard, and the
ID is incorrect.
And again, that's probably
something where you would get
back an error in the client,
but it's a little hard for
that error to get sent to
you, the developer.
At least it was in the past.
Now when we notice this
is happening a lot,
we will alert you.
And you'll start to see, OK, my
application apparently is
trying to do unlock
this achievement
that doesn't exist.
Maybe I did a copy and paste
error or something.
You can start looking
into that.
So be sure to go and visit
the developer console.
Look for these alerts.
They will come in very handy.
In addition, we are now giving
you twice the cloud.
So we have this service Cloud
Save, generally designed for
games, which is a very simple,
hey, just save my data to the
cloud, load it somewhere else.
It's great if you've got
developers or if you've got
players that are playing your
game on multiple devices.
They can carry their progress
from one device to the next.
And in the past, we had
four slots of 128k
available to you.
And now, check out
these effects.
Bam!
We are moving to four
slots of 256k each.
So that's twice the cloud.
That's the 1,024k total.
Hopefully, that's enough for
you to save a pretty decent
save game file.
So make use of that.
And finally, there is a
new Google+ iOS SDK.
This is not specifically related
to Game Services.
This is related to anything
you'd want to do with Google+.
So you non-game developers as
well, if you're looking to
share anything on Google+, this
is relevant to you, too.
There are a number of
enhancements to this SDK.
But the biggest thing
you'll notice is the
native share box.
It used to be that if you wanted
to share something from
a game or an application to
Google+, you had to basically
switch out of your app or your
game and over into a browser,
Mobile Safari, something like
that, so that you could share
on Google+.
And it wasn't a great
experience.
I mean, you left your app to go
into a browser so that you
could post this thing.
So now the new experience--
ooh, got some more
effects there--
is much nicer.
This is a native share box, so
it basically pops up within
your application.
The user doesn't have
to leave it.
They don't have to swap out.
And they can share directly
through Google+ from there.
In addition, this native share
box has some features that let
you upload and share
a photo or a video.
This is great for you
game developers.
You can take a screenshot of
your game, and you can add
that in to the native share
box and share right there.
So it makes for a much more
interesting post when someone
can share exactly the cool
thing that's happening in
their game when they
share this stuff.
So we will update our
sample code to show
you how to do that.
Make sure to view the Google+
documentation.
It basically gives you all the
code snippets you'll need to
get that working.
Also, watch out by the way.
I think there are four new
frameworks that you're going
to have to add into your
application that you didn't
have to before.
Again, all that is available on
the Google+ documentation
side of things.
So if you want more
information, you
can check that out.
And I believe that concludes
this week's episode of "Game
On." Go to your developer
console.
Check out those stats.
I think it's pretty
interesting.
And we will see you
in a couple weeks.
Thanks, game developers.